foreign
Louis Vuitton bags chewed up designer
heels damaged Chanel handbags and worn
out Gucci sneakers these accessories
have seen better days we follow
professionals as they restore nine
luxury items
[Music]
our first expert is Rio Junction from
Kim shrew and bag repair he shows us how
he mends these a thousand dollar Gucci
mules making them look brand new
foreign
[Music]
on a pair of Gucci loafers that retail
for around one thousand dollars one of
my customers brought me her shoe that
was bitten by hard dog the biggest
problem with this shoe is that her dog
chewed the tall area of a shoe so the
Raider is completely cracked and broken
I'm going to repair broken rather on the
tall area and also clean the shoe and
refinish it
I'm wiping off the dust and debris from
the shoe with a horsehair brush to
prevent the shoe from any scratches by
their wrist while cleaning the shoe
[Music]
now I'm applying a leather of the sieve
to a glue cracked leather pieces
foreign
I have to be careful when I'm gluing
broken rather pieces not to make more
damage on rather
I'm gently pressing the bite marks to
glue the tone rather back onto the shoe
and then slowly moving a roller over the
leather to make them firmly attached
[Music]
I'm taking some more amounts of the
leather pillar and gently spread the
filler over the cracks with a palette
knife until the crack appeals filled
and then tilting the edge of the palette
knife Slide the waist and gently
scraping off the excess filler
[Music]
now I'm using a rotary tool to sand down
the rather filler on the damaged surface
until it gets smooth
when I use the rotary tool to stand down
I have to be careful about the control
of pressing Force
if I press too hard it could dig the
surface
foreign
[Music]
a leather cleaner with soft forced hair
brush to clean the shoe because it
Cutlery when the dog played with the
shoe
[Music]
I am mixing up rather paints to match
the color of the shoe and then applying
it with acrylic paints brush to the
repair area
[Music]
now I'm applying a leather paint with
acrylic paint brush to repaint color
faded edges of the shoe
[Music]
foreign
spray onto the shoe to prevent the water
from being observed
[Music]
foreign
for around 750 dollars
so he plays haven't worn out so now I'm
thinking of the order heel plates with
an opener for the replacement
now I'm sending the leather bottom
source of the shoes to make them even
and also open up the surface to enhance
audition as I attach the leather soles
with new rubber soles later
[Music]
thank you
the bottom of the shoes have become worn
out so they need protection soles
I'm preparing new Robo stores and lower
heel plates
I'm drawing a line in pencil to Mark
where the new Soul goes
[Music]
foreign
stores have become detached so now I'm
applying a leather glue to reattach them
[Music]
I'm using a glue brush to apply leather
glue to the bottom of those shoes where
the new rubber soles goes
I'm raving shoes for around 20 minutes
to dry the glue on the bottom of those
shoes before I'm adding a second coats
foreign
to warm up the both leather soles and
lower soles to all the hair better
[Music]
I'm using a hammer to press new source
onto the shoes
[Music]
now I'm cutting the edge of lower soles
and hip plates with knife
foreign
[Music]
motion to trim the edgy of shoes
I'm using a horsehair brush and suede
brush to remove dust from the shoes
foreign
[Music]
ER to clean the suede area with a suede
cleaning brush
[Music]
thank you
especially I have to be more careful
with Reviving faded suede because the
color was
irregularly faded and some part of
Sweden app was missed
[Music]
I'm brushing the shoes after cleaning
them to reflock the Sweet tile
[Music]
foreign
now I'm using a masking tape to cover
known suede area to avoid any damage
from dying's weight
[Music]
I'm using a paintbrush to apply suede
dye to suede area and doing this a
couple of times
[Music]
the Raider on the shoes have become
scuffed and Faded so I'm going to read
the item
I'm using a black leather die with a
paintbrush to re-dye the leather
[Music]
I'm using a leather paint to retouch up
the edge of the shoes
[Music]
I'm applying a finisher to leather
toolbox and leather sole edges to
protect paints from minor scratches or
scraps
now I'm applying a waterproofing spray
to protect shoes from water damage mink
oil is a product made from the fairy
layer under mink skins
it took a cup of rock days to complete
the repair
foreign
for around 680 dollars
these shoes were by one of my clients
Unfortunately they were not maintained
well there are three main things to be
restored first of all the rubber stores
are stained so they need to be removed
second leather upper gets cough so they
need to be repainted and refinished
lastly metallic Panner at the back is
faded so it needs to be retouched
[Music]
I'm taking off the shoe races and
insource from the shoes
[Music]
now I'm using a toothbrush to remove the
dust from the inside of the shoes before
cleaning because this dust or sand can
cause some scratches on leather while
I'm cleaning
I'm using a leather cleaner with a soft
hair brush and gently moving the brush
in a circular motion to clean the
interior and exterior of the shoes
[Music]
now I'm wiping off the foam and water
quickly to avoid any water damage
[Music]
the Rover swords are dirty and stained
so I'm brushing them to clean out the
dirt first and using a thinner scrubbing
off the stain with leg
s
metallic green Penner is originally made
of leather and printed with metallic
snake skin shaped layer
when people try to wear the shoes they
tend to touch hold and bend the heel
area
I'm using a leather glue with on all to
glue the pilt metallic back on
it's very hard to find the exactly same
paint color to match the green metallic
pattern since it's not even one solid
color I have to mix several paint colors
to make the light and shade of metallic
Penner
foreign
[Music]
of the shoes are scuffed and discolored
some areas
so I'm using a leather paint to touch up
those cuffed area first and applying
evenly all over the shoes
[Music]
I'm using a matte finisher to protect
the paint from peeling off four cracks
foreign
shoe races are not clean over like the
original condition so I'm replacing with
the new ones
now I'm applying Shield yodelizer to
eliminate odor and keep fresh
[Music]
I'm very excited for my clients to see
this installation
foreign
[Music]
Steck and I'm co-founder and CEO of
handbag clinic today I'm going to walk
you through how our Artisan Chloe will
restore this Grand Chapel toad that has
pen ink all over it the Chanel Grand
Shopper tote reached around two thousand
pounds when it was able to be bought
direct from Chanel when this restoration
is complete we would sell a grand
Chopper tote for anywhere between 1 700
pounds and 1950 pounds
foreign
[Music]
will do with this item is remove all of
the ink the most important part of
restoring this bag will actually be the
initial cleaning because ink can spread
and can create more staining
we use a special ink remover so you can
see Chloe taking the ink remover with a
small cotton bud and gently rolling this
over the initial ink this is so that we
don't have any spreading any further
contamination of that ink to the bag
one of the main reasons for this is
because ink is actually very oily and
oil and leather really don't mix
[Music]
we then also use a range of products
some are solvent based which will help
to dry out any areas which have absorbed
additional oils
and then we also use products which have
natural oils embedded into them which
will then nourish areas that have dried
such as the corners
or any areas where the ink has been
drawn out of
[Music]
we then use our specialist cleaning
solution with the brush and a foam which
then will remove any excess product
caviar skin leather is grained so you
need the brush to get into all of those
grooves to be able to really make sure
it's clean and make sure it's ready for
the next stage of the process caviar
leather it gets its name from being a
petal texture leather which means that
it has printed into it this almost
bubbled effect
if anything is trapped there or left in
there you would run the risk of that
late appealing or coming away
[Music]
because it is ink that is contaminated
with this the cleaning process alone
will not remove this stain and we must
apply other methods
[Music]
in our research and development team we
realized that ink stains in particular
were very stubborn so we created a
metallic solution which actually blocks
that coming through to make sure in a
year's time you're not going to stop
seeing that ink stain come through
Chloe takes the specialist solution and
she applies it lightly with an airbrush
throughout every area where you can see
the ink
Chloe will then create the color match
which we have discussed with the client
in advance
this colorant once created will then be
airbrushed on this bag
[Music]
we always want to be as sparing as
possible to ensure the texture of the
leather is maintained
because of the iconic CC quilting and
the CC on the front of the item which
makes this item the iconic Chanel look
we want to make sure as little pigment
gets onto those stitches as possible
and the bag is ready to go
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER of Royal gloss restoration Studio
here in Russia and I'm the head
restoration artist there today I'm going
to walk you through how we restored this
42 000 Celine crocodile back it was made
around eight years ago and they were
producing it for one year only this
makes it really rare there was a huge
amount of problems on it there was a
scuffs and scratches all over the back
the lining inside the bag was completely
messed up the bag was missing the puller
for the zipper
foreign
we start with removing the edge paint
all the edges of the back have scuffs
and scratches
we use the grinder to sand it down
we begin with disassembling the back
[Music]
the inner lining had a lot of scratches
from active use as well it had some dirt
stains to clean and fix at the inner
lining we had to pull apart all the back
the tools that we used were seam ripper
and cobbler knife the seam Reaper is
more preferred for delicates parts of
the bag
[Music]
we carefully slide under the Stitch and
pull the Stitch upward to get it out
[Music]
the original lining for Celine crocodile
back is made of sheepskin
we also use sheepskin with the same
quality with the same color and the same
softness
after we carefully took off all the
sheepskin Linings from each side of the
back we replaced them with the new ones
[Music]
to cut the new lining out we used a
rotary cutter
[Music]
the glue that we use is the same that
manufacturer use
[Music]
it has a very strong bonding
in order to make a new zipper for a bag
we use the new zipper
we use new leather we choose a pattern
to match the original scales and we
painted the same color as the back
in order to clean the handbag we use a
special leather shampoo and a semi soft
brush
when we talk about cleaning the
crocodile skin it is difficult because
you can damage the patina even with a
mild cleaner you can just wipe it out
[Music]
one of the biggest concerns is the
scales which cracked on the handle if
it's not prevented in time later it will
be very difficult to repair them
it's also had greasy stains on it so in
order to remove the stains and for a
paint to penetrate through the handle
and to have a bond with a surface we
need to use acetone to remove the
aggressive stains
applying an edge paint coat is essential
part to keep all the edges sealed and
prevent the back from further moisture
penetration
to apply the edge paint we use a special
roller pen it wraps a certain amount of
edge paint and allows to allocate it to
the edges
in order to color match I'm testing
colors on separate crocodile leather
skin
I'm trying to mimic The Fading that goes
from the center to the edges from Blue
to dark blue and then to the black it
gives back a very unique look
[Music]
in order to apply the paint I'm using
airbrush and small spray gun
working with them allows me to
accurately distribute paint all over the
surface
[Music]
we use water-based paints which will
cover up all the defects
these kinds of paints have a great
adhesion properties
[Music]
we had two types of sewing machines to
get the same old Stitch holes
we regulate the length between the holes
one of the sewing machines was primarily
used to suit the thickest part of the
ladder
[Music]
we had to be careful with assembling the
back back together because while
assembling all the sides of the bag we
had to consider the thickness of the
leather layers so they won't move during
this sewing process
for some parts we did a hand swing to
avoid damaging the crocodile leather
[Music]
thank you
my name is Tom Rego and I am the
co-owner of Rego Brothers shoe and
leather repair with my brother Tony Rago
and today I am going to walk you through
a dog chewed Louboutin shoe
approximate cost is eight hundred
dollars to one thousand dollars when
they came into us the platform was
halfway chewed off the top of the shoe
wasn't there and the heels were all
chewed all had bite marks on it and you
would think that this was an
unrepairable shoe we are going to
attempt to rebuild the platform of this
shoe the upper part the black patent
leather and get the structure back to
the shoe
please
to start out the process we are going to
give this to our repairman Ronnie who is
going to put this shoe together
we are using a heat gun to remove the
platform very carefully trying to loosen
the glue between the shoe and the
platform
we now are putting the platform down on
the table and taking a piece of bonded
leather and tracing out the platform so
that we can make a mold for the other
shoe
[Music]
what that involved is flipping the
platform over so it looked like a left
shoe instead of the right shoe so we did
that we took our measurements
[Music]
once we've got that pattern we now are
taking a hard piece of rubber and we are
shaping that with a Dremel to match the
other platform
the platform when you get it from
Louboutin it's a molded plastic base
molded plastic is not available to us so
we cut it out of a very rigid piece of
rubber and we had to sand it to make the
exact curves that it needed to have to
fit the upper part of the shoe
[Music]
when you start with the upper part of
the shoe you take a flat piece of patent
leather and you take the inside material
which is a bonded leather that gives it
the structure that gives it the form
[Music]
what we're doing now is we're heating up
the leather on the platform so that we
can stretch it make it more malleable so
that it has no creases in it and then we
pull it and attach it to the platform
[Music]
so now we have the top shape of the shoe
after we've gotten that we begin to form
it to the platform underneath
[Music]
we have to mold that platform around the
top of the shoe and that requires us
using a hand Dremel to get the shape of
the platform to fit onto the upper part
of the shoe that's just trial and error
that you may go through that several
times
[Music]
so now that we've repaired the upper
part of the shoe we're going to take the
platform and attach the platform to the
upper part of the shoe
foreign
Henry
[Music]
so that he can attach the leather and
Rubber Sole to the bottom of the shoe
now what we're doing is we're attaching
the red sole onto the bottom of the shoe
[Music]
we are going to take this shoe and we
are going to Edge it with black paint so
that from the side of the shoe all you
see is the black you won't see any red
foreign
[Music]
for us and we think it came out really
great we think that when the owner does
get this shoe back her mouth is gonna
drop
[Music]
foreign
Gallagher Master leather Craftsman and
founder of lead the surgeons today we
have a black caviar Chanel classic flak
jumbo bag that's been severely damaged
by incandescent light bulb we had this
customer reach out to us she did a
closet restoration actually and somehow
an incandescent light pole from a
contractor burned its way clear through
her handbag through the outer flap or
through the lining but what I'm going to
try to do here is just graft new leather
over the damaged area and preserve as
much of the original part of the bag as
I possibly can
foreign
[Music]
I'm going to start by opening up all the
stitches around the front flap of the
back
[Music]
we're going to use a sewing all and a
really sharp knife to be able to just
you know get in between the lining of
the bag and the shell of the bag without
causing any damage I like to pull out
the stitches one at a time because
eventually when we stitch this bag back
together we're going to have to stitch
in the same exact holes that the
manufacturer has stitching in the first
time
foreign
up the two gusset tacks so that we could
access the interior lining of the bag
between the shell and the lining of the
bag and see just how much we need to do
as far as replacing the internals
[Music]
the burn went completely through the
outer shell and through the interior
lining of the bag
foreign
[Music]
part of this job we have the damaged
area in the lower right quadrant
so it would be much easier for me to
take the front panel off and just
recreate the front panel but what I'd
like to do is preserve as much of the
front panel of the bag as I possibly can
and just replace the part that's damaged
so I'm going to take my knife and I'm
going to very carefully skive off which
means cut away the existing leather
that's burned or damaged
I'm going to make our little pattern and
I'm going to replace that piece of
leather
[Music]
I use a pattern to cut the size of the
front panel and make sure it's 100
accurate
[Music]
because the bag was so severely damaged
and it was burned completely through and
actually clear through the interior
lining I'm going to cut fresh lining
panels
we have patterns already pre-cut for
this particular bag
the interior lining of the bag is made
of goats so we replace it with goat as
far as Chanel this bag is Chanel caviar
leather which we also stock
we're able to replace everything about
this bag exactly the way it was done the
first time
I'm going to take that piece of caviar
leather and I'm going to hand Skype it
which means shave it down
[Music]
if I Sky the leather paper thin and I
lay it right along that line when I drop
my new Stitch over that seam there'll be
a zero transition between what was there
before and what we have now
it should completely disappear
I'm going to lie and cement that piece
of leather right over that seam
this is a traditional leather contact
cement so you need to apply the cement
to both surfaces give it a minute or two
to set and then press the pieces
together
[Music]
when you're doing a restoration and you
want to put the Stitch back in the
Stitch hole that was there before you
need to aim the needle for the hole so
when I re-quilt this leather any
stitches that are visible I have to make
sure I drop the stitch in the same exact
hole
it's just a question of measuring
everything out because the flap quilting
has to match the body of the bag
quilting when you close that bag all of
those seams should line up
foreign
the leather of the chain this customer
felt that the patina on the gold was
starting to fade a little bit so we
replayed the metal
[Music]
then I'm going to re-weave that leather
through the chain and Stitch the two
ends
[Music]
foreign
I feel really good about what we did
here today we took a bag that would have
otherwise been trashed and we gave it a
new lease on life
I'm talene kopian co-founder of purse
rehab we are a designer handbag and
leather goods Restoration company today
I'm going to walk you through how my
team restores a burnt Louis Vuitton
Neverfull bag this is the damier a bean
Never full print it's their top selling
bag today this bag is about two thousand
dollars depending on the size
unfortunately the bag was left by
accident on a burning electric stove top
so the entire base is basically burnt
along with the piping and the side of
the bag is also burnt
foreign
to start we're going to unstitch the
base and in order to do that we're using
a round all to remove the stitching and
remove the piping as well
we're going to clean off some of the
debris here using a soft bristle brush
this is a coated Canvas Bag basically
coated canvas is cotton that's coated
with polyvinyl fluoride so that's why
you have that black color and the
hardness of the canvas
now we are drawing the template using
the base that we removed
and we are using cowhide leather this is
premium leather that matches the
existing trim on the bag we're going to
also skive the base at the edges skiving
is essentially shaving down the leather
and it's usually done at the edges so
that they're easily foldable or
stitchable
to match the interior Red Canvas of the
bag we are cutting a new piece of red
material to glue on and Stitch onto the
base so that the interior is fully
compatible with the existing lining and
it's very much like the Louis Vuitton
material
we have to make a new piping to add to
the base this is made out of the same
leather
and so we cut out the piping and glue it
onto the base
and in addition to gluing it we will
also be stitching the piping so that
it's double reinforcement simply gluing
it isn't going to give it that extra
strength that it needs because it is a
basil it's a stress point on the back
in addition to making the base we are
going to recreate the burnt piece that's
on the side of the bag we are using
recycled Louis Vuitton material that's
in the domiera bean print so that it
looks more seamless and it Blends in
nicely with the bag
we try to align the pattern on the back
first visually to make sure that we can
make it fit once we cut it we are going
to glue it onto the canvas and also
Stitch it
and once the Recycled pieces on the bag
we're going to trim off the excess burnt
portion that's underneath the bag
once we've completed the preparation of
the new base it's time to put it on the
bag first we glue it onto the bag using
leather glue and then we are stapling
the base onto the body of the bag it's a
unique feature that our Craftsmen use
here so that when we're stitching it
together it's solid and it doesn't move
once we're done stitching the base onto
the bag we are removing the Staples
using a round tipped staple remover
which does not damage the canvas or the
leather
foreign
once we're done with the structural
issues and the repairs on the back we're
cleaning it using a mild cleaner to
revitalizing condition the canvas
it would have been impossible for us to
match the exact same pattern and
material we did our best to come up with
a solution that does blend well with the
bag and makes it usable in the long run
and that essentially was our client's
goal
foreign
a handbag Restoration company in Sydney
Australia
today I'm going to walk you through how
I restore a four thousand dollar Chanel
vanity case
took a love a bag at this age the lining
is disintegrating it is a coated fabric
we also have wear and tear to the outer
corners
this bag was purchased 10 years ago for
1500 US Dollars it is today worth
between three thousand and five thousand
dollars so in its restored state it will
be worth more towards five thousand
dollars
to begin the process I'm going to remove
the strap from the bag so I'm going to
do this using some small pliers to
gently remove the chain from the link
the strap is very worn so there is color
wear dirt buildup and the metal work is
tarnished I'm then going to take a quick
unpick and undo the stitches at the end
of the chain I now need to unthread the
leather through the chain so that it's
completely separated from the metal work
foreign
[Music]
I'm going to clean the strap
so the leather strap will just be
cleaned initially with foam cleaner
so I'm doing this with a horse hair hide
brush which is nice and gentle to get
into the grain of the leather
[Music]
and then I'm going to continue this
process throughout the exterior of the
bag so I'm just applying foam cleaner to
the bag surface doing one panel at a
time
I'm gently massaging the foam into the
rain of the leather
[Music]
it is always important to clean the bag
before applying pigment this will mean
that the pigments will bond to the
leather better if there's anything left
on the surface of the bag such as
silicones from protector sprays or
day-to-day dirt buildup this could
hinder the bonding process
[Music]
now I'm going to clean the interior of
the bag
I just need to clean as much of the
debris away as possible so I'm using a
much more gentle cleaner here which is
like a luxury leather cleaner so it's a
water-based cleaner and I'm basically
just going to gently wipe inside the
lining
this has to be done really gently as if
any pressure is put on or if a product
that was incorrect was used it will then
start to remove even more of the lining
we need to preserve as much of the
original Island as possible to make the
job easier in the restoring stage
now we've fully cleaned the bag inside
and out I'm going to move over to the
repair process
the interior of the bag is
disintegrating this is quite common with
this age bag as it was made from a
coated fabric over time and due to
humidity the surface of the lining will
start to crumble and come away we need
to restore the lining as close to the
original as possible so we're going to
rebuild the surface using fillers and
pigments
so here I'm going to use a flexible
filler and this filler moves with the
surface of the leather or fabric so I'm
just going to apply this using a very
soft and small paintbrush so I can get a
nice even surface across the whole
interior lining the idea is to restore
the original and avoid having to replace
something like this this means we retain
the original Chanel logo
I'm going to do this very slowly to make
sure that I get a good even coverage all
the way around I'm going to start using
the filler along the top rim and then
work my way down into the main crevices
of the lining once applied this filler
needs 24 hours to cure
now I've left the filler for 24 hours
I'm sanding down the surface so this is
to remove any sort of bits of grain or
lumps or bumps and try and get a smooth
finish I'm just going to start sanding
around the top really gently I'm using a
very fine sandpaper so it doesn't grab
or wear down the surface of the original
lining
and I'm then going to wipe over with
some alcohol
this will remove any of the surface dust
that has been created from the Sandpaper
and then it will also slightly soften
the filler to help it smooth and blend
into the original surface of the lining
foreign
[Music]
brushing I'm just going to remove the CC
lock Hardware this makes it much easier
to get an even coat around the lock I'm
just going to unscrew this with a small
flathead screwdriver
once I've removed that I'm going to tape
up the remaining Hardware on the bag
so now I'm just going to move on to
mixing a color for the bag I custom mix
every color by eyes but I tend to use
about three or four paints and to mix
each color so here I'm using caramel
gold yellow and Citron
I mix these together and I'm just going
to test the color on a small area in the
bag to make sure it matches this can
take a few attempts sometimes just to
make sure the color is absolutely soft
on
now I've got my color and I'm good to go
I'm just going to pop it into an
airbrush
if I use the airbrush as it allows me to
create lots of fine coats of pigment
rather than painting it on which would
go on too thick
it's really important not to too heavy
coat a bag with paints pigments and
fillers less is always more so we still
want to preserve the original look and
feel of the bag
I'm just going to work my way around
each section of the bag concentrating on
the areas that have more wear
now I've managed to get a nice coat of
pigment over all of the bag I'm then
going to use a finish
a finish is a clear coat sealant which
goes on top of the pigment to protect it
from wear and tear here I've mixed about
two thirds high gloss to the third map
to get a nice satin Sheen which reflects
the original leather
I'm just gonna airbrush this finish over
the whole bag and then leave it to dry
now moving on to the leather in the
strap I'm actually going to paint this
on with a paintbrush so as not to have
too much wasted pain so I'm just going
to run all the way along the strap with
one coat leave it to dry and then repeat
the process I'm then going to finish
this off again with airbrushing the
finish for a nice even layer across the
whole strap
now I'm going to move on to the lining
I'm going to take my paintbrush and
paint in over all of the areas where the
surface have chipped away this may take
a few coats as it was shown white
underneath but I need to rebuild the
color back up to match the surface
lining
foreign
[Music]
once I've done that I'm going to apply a
finish due to the severity of the
condition of this lining there will
still remain a few imperfections but
what we have done is we've sealed and
recoated the surface so this will
prevent any further damage from
happening and give this handbag a new
lease online
[Music]
now that I've completed all of the
airbrushing I am now going to polish the
hardware
there I'm going to use a fine gray metal
polish to just gently polish the surface
of the metal this will remove any of the
tarnishing as I'm doing so you can see
the dark color the tarnished metal work
coming off onto the convert
I'm going to polish all the links on the
strap to bring them up to a nice Shiny
Gold
now all the color work is done I'm going
to reattach the strap I'm going to
firstly re-thread the leather through
the strap it's really important that you
align the lever up properly so that you
get the same amount each end I am now
using the pliers to reattach the chain
to the bag now I need to stitch the
leather back together through the
original holes and taking some matching
color thread and using a very fine
needle so I can get through the original
holes it's really important to go
through the original holes as if you
make a new hole in leather there's no
way of reversing that without them going
through another repair process
I'm just going to secure with a couple
of stitches and then tie it in on itself
to keep it neat
and now I just need to thread the end
back through the leather and then secure
it with a little bit of glue just like
it was originally going to say
and now I'm going to apply a leather
protector to the surface of the leather
this will protect the bag from dye
transfer from jeans UV damage and liquid
and oil staining it's really important
to protect your liver bags for future
wear and tear
foreign
I'm really happy how the restoration of
this bag turned out the interior is now
ready to be worn and the lining is all
fixed up the outside is no longer
showing any signs of wear and tear and
the Gold Hardware is looking nice and
shiny I think my customer is going to be
really pleased with the outcome
[Music]
foreign